this week is pretty major from the point
of view that's not just putting in
traffic signals it's also replacing and
upgrading
uh sewer pipes storm water pipes and
water main so it's a pretty major piece
of work
we suggest commuters look at alternative
routes to avoid the intersection because
the more traffic that uses the
intersection the more delays they'll be
some of those alternatives are for
people living on the west side of
rangiora there's the fernside flaxton
townsend road
link and that and that provides a direct
connection into the western side of
rangiora
for the east and north there's possibly
using grandeur wood end road as a as a
route that will avoid southbrook road so
they are the two main routes that people
should consider
if people have to use the intersection
then we'd suggest they avoid the peak
time and peak times are at school start
and finish times and also from about
four o'clock onwards in the evenings it
gets pretty
congested so
it's just avoiding those times if you
can